>> Good afternoon.
And I hope you've been
having a wonderful time
at the National Book Festival.
I'm Carla Hayden, the Library of
Congress, and I am so excited --
[ Applause ]
To introduce our next
writer and illustrator--
Of so many amazing books.
You know who I'm
talking about, don't you?
Because he's right here.
Mr. Brian Selznick.
And I think that deserves a
big hand before I say all these
other wonderful things.
[ Applause ]
Now you know that his books have
garnered countless accolades
around the world and
have been translated
into more than 35 languages.
He is the Caldecott
Medal winning creator
of the number one New York
Times best sellers The Invention
of Hugo adapted into
an Oscar-winning movie
and Wonderstruck.
I think we need more,
more, more.
This is -- because
it gets better.
He's also written the New York
Times bestsellers the Marvels
and Baby Monkey, Private
Eye, one of my favorites.
So it has been 20 years since
the first Harry Potter book,
and we are celebrating
the anniversary,
the 20th anniversary, with
the publication by Scholastic
of a new edition and
series with covers
by our wonderful illustrator.
Now he's going to
tell you all about it,
and if you haven't read
the series yet, please do.
If you want to re-read
it, please do,
because Brian is
marvelous, and he is going
to be interviewed today
by Barrie Hardymon,
MPR's Weekend Edition book
editor, also someone that lived
in my hometown of Baltimore.
So she's going to interview
him and please join me
in welcoming Brian Selznick.
[ Applause ]
>> Wow. Thank you.
>> I have to tell you,
I'm a little starstruck.
>> Can we have a round of
applause for Dr. Hayden, please?
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
Making the Library of Congress
accessible to all of us,
everyone in the country.
Thank you for all of the work
you do opening up the doors
and making us feel welcome here
at the greatest library
in the world.
[ Applause ]
So thank you all so much.
I'm going to do a brief
presentation about the making
of the Harry Potter
books before we sit down
and have our interview together.
So -- I don't have that much
time, so I just started --
I want to start when I was 10,
so we have 42 years
to get through.
I always drew when I was a kid.
These are some drawings
that I did when I was young.
I used to like to
copy famous artists.
This is a copy of an angel
that I did by da Vinci.
I also liked to draw monsters.
I got in trouble sometimes
for drawing monsters
when I was a kid, but all
of these things were always
a big part of my life.
And eventually I got a job at
Eeyore's Books for Children,
which some of us remember as one
of the best bookstores anywhere,
and that's really
where I learned how
to be a children's book
illustrator and how
to make books for children.
I used to paint the windows
for different holidays.
This, of course, was
our Christmas window.
And my first book came out
while I was still working
at Eeyore's Books for Children,
The Houdini Box, and then I went
on and I made many other books,
some of which were set here
in Washington, DC, like Walt
Whitman, Words for America,
and Amelia and Eleanor
Go for a Ride.
And I was living in
Washington DC with my husband,
David Serlin, while I
was making this book,
and he had a fellowship
at the Smithsonian.
And so I went on from there
to make these three books,
which formed a kind of trilogy,
The Invention of Hugo Cabret,
Wonderstruck, and The
Marvels, which are books
that tell stories
with a combination
of words and pictures.
And so when I got the call
to illustrate the new covers
for Harry Potter, I -- well,
immediately I was terrified,
like my first response
was complete terror,
because the entire world
loves Harry Potter.
But I, myself, was a
fan of Harry Potter.
I had read the books for the
first time two years prior
to getting this phone call, and
I really fell in love with them.
I was so moved by the
characters, by the relationships
between everybody in the books,
by the battle between good
and evil, especially by Dobby.
Dobby was my favorite character.
I'm a Hufflepuff, by the way.
I don't know if we have any
Hufflepuffs in the house.
And so while I was talking
to Scholastic on the phone,
and they were offering this
incredible opportunity to me,
I was told that I had two weeks
to design all seven covers
and hand in the sketches
in order to get approval,
and if I get approved,
then I could go ahead
and do the artwork.
And while I was on the
phone, I had a vision
for what I wanted
the covers to be.
I wanted them to be black
and white, and I wanted them
to all line up so that they
would tell a single story
from the first book to the last
book, like JK Rowling does,
of the story of Harry Potter,
his growing up, and his battle
with good and evil, and
his friends and family.
And so when I was
working on Hugo,
because one of the things I
wanted to say was that all
of the things I learned
making all of my books
up until Harry Potter, went
into helping me make the
Harry Potter book covers
as good as I possibly could.
And so one of the things
I did when I was working
on the Invention of Hugo Cabret,
was I illustrated a dream
sequence in the story that I did
as one long drawing, and then
I divided that one long drawing
up into five spreads, so that
when you get to the book,
the dream sequence
feels like it's flowing
from one page into the next.
And I remember doing that
single drawing and I thought,
that is what will
be my inspiration
for the Harry Potter covers.
And so the first thing I did
was I sat down and I drew
out seven little book
covers next to each other
and I started drawing lines,
because I wanted to figure
out how to connect all
of them and I thought
like a swirling line
would connect them.
And I realized that
that swirling line looks
like a snake.
And that reminded me of
Nagini, and if you're a fan
of the books, you know
that Nagini is connected
with Voldemort and
it represents evil.
And I thought that would be how
I could represent the battle
of good and evil is that
snake could wind all the way
through the books, from
Book One to Book Seven,
where the snake is -- where
we see the snake's head
on Book Seven, and we have
an intimation, a hint,
of what happens at the end.
Because one of the challenges
when you're doing book covers
is you want to make covers
that are interesting
to the fans,
that they can identify with,
but it also has to bring
in new readers, so you don't
want to give away the ending.
So I took that first sketch,
I started adding more details,
and I handed in my first
sketch in one week.
I did this in less than a week.
I got approval from
Scholastic, we got approval
from JK Rowling's entire team,
and then I spent the next
several months working out all
of the details for these covers.
So if you look at
these sketches,
as we look at the detailed
versions, you'll see some things
that change, you'll see some
things that stay the same,
but you'll notice that the
seventh book is the one
that changes the most.
So notice here I have Harry
grown up, holding the head
of the snake, and
then that changes.
Now you can see he's
got his two friends,
but I've got more
details worked in.
And you can see I'm labeling
some of the characters,
because I knew for the
fans I wanted to have lots
of little Easter eggs
where you would be able
to recognize things
from the books
that if you haven't
read the books,
you might not know
what they are.
And I had to draw
this giant snake.
And so I wanted to make
sure that the scales
for the snake all lined
up in the correct way,
so I did one giant drawing.
This drawing is actually this
big, to make sure that I got all
of the loops of the
snake correct.
And then I began working out
what I wanted each of the covers
to look like, in detail,
and these are four different
versions of that final cover,
where you can see me
working towards the one
that eventually became the
cover that I ended up using.
And I don't really do very
much work on the computer.
I draw everything by hand.
I have a Xerox machine, a
copy machine, in my studio
and I do print things out
or take a digital photograph
and print it out and I will
then I'll photocopy a drawing
and then I'll enlarge it or
shrink it on my photocopier
like it's 1997, and then
I will cut things out
and rearrange them
and move them around.
And so you can see on
the wall of my studio,
one of the drawings I did of
Harry as a kid, one of the ones
that I did of him
a little older,
so that I could move the
elements around a little bit,
the way people who work
on the computer might do
that with Photoshop,
I literally cut
and paste everything together.
And so here you can see a cut
and pasted version of the cover
of the books, the big mural, and
I'm beginning to find the places
where each of the details
are going to work together.
And so I got to go to Harry
Potter World in the middle
of all this to meet 75,000 Harry
Potter fans, and let me just say
that completely freaked
me out in terms
of the pressure and
the expectations.
But what they reminded
me, ultimately,
was that we're all
Harry Potter fans,
and I'm a Harry Potter fan
offering other Harry Potter fans
my version of this world.
But I got to meet someone
who had Dobby with her,
and so I got my own Dobby,
and me and my husband
now live with Dobby.
We're very happy.
I think Dobby's very happy.
And so then I began
doing the drawing.
And so that became the
final image for the covers.
And I started at the first
drawing and worked my way left
to right, and I put on an audio
recording of Harry Potter read
by Jim Dale, at the beginning
of this drawing, and I listened
to all seven of the books
while I was doing the drawings,
and I actually was
keeping pace with the story
as I was working my
way across the covers
and I have a magnifying glass
that was helping me out.
And this actually
didn't help at all.
[ Laughing ]
And so by the time
I got to the end
and I was drawing the
final battle of Hogwarts,
I was actually listening
to the Battle of Hogwarts
in the stories themselves.
Hold on, I just have
to do one thing.
My computer froze.
I'm just going to move ahead
this way and then go back.
And so I had the
finished artwork finally,
and then we were able to choose
colors for each of the titles
that were representative of
something from the book itself.
And so I'm going to now tell
you a few little secrets
from each of the covers.
Harry Potter's glasses are
actually glasses I wore
in the movie version of my book
Wonderstruck that was directed
by Todd Haynes, starring
Julianne Moore.
And so those are Harry Potter --
those became Harry
Potter's glasses.
And so Aragog, there,
the spider, was inspired
by a sculpture by
Louise Bourgeois,
who likes to make giant spiders
that are inspired by her mother,
because she sees spiders
as very nurturing.
These figures, the
Dementors, are inspired
by these grieving monks,
these sculptures that I saw
at the Met, which
were also inspirations
for graveyard figures in
the movie version of Hugo.
And Fleur Delacour
in the Triwizarding Competition
was directly inspired
by the movie star Veronica Lake.
And this centaur
was inspired by one
of the sculptures
on The Parthenon.
And I had to draw what, for me,
was the most horrifying villain
in the entire series,
Dolores Umbridge,
because she's a bureaucrat,
she's a hypocrite,
she says she's doing good,
but is actually doing evil.
I think we can all
make parallels
to people in our world.
[ Applause ]
And because she's the one who,
to me, is the most realistic
and the most recognizable,
she's also the most terrifying.
So I had to find someone
to represent this
embodiment of evil.
So, of course, I
turned to my husband.
[ Laughing ]
Dumbledore is Michelangelo's
Moses.
And then I got to
do the box set,
so I got to do these
quick little sketches
about what I wanted
the box to look like.
I got to redesign all
of the house crests,
which was very exciting.
And then this is the exterior
of the box, Harry Potter,
but I love how Harry has
some of Voldemort in him,
Voldemort has some of Harry
in him, good and evil are --
it's a very, very
complicated game that's played.
It's a very, very
complicated dance
as good tries to
win out over evil.
So when you take out all of
the books in the box set,
this is what you find inside.
So there's Voldemort
waiting for you inside.
So as we put all
of them together --
[ Music ]
That became the series.
Thank you very much.
>> That's okay.
>> Thank you.
Hi.
>> Hi.
>> How are you?
>> I'm well.
So since we only
have five minutes,
I'm going to ask you the
thing that I'm going to talk
about the thing in this picture
that just moves me the most,
which is that -- and I heard
that you loved to draw babies,
and there are two babies
in this, and I want you
to talk about both of them.
So at the beginning, you have
little baby Harry being left
on the doorstep.
At the end, well --
>> Yeah, so because I wanted
to draw the whole story
and encapsulate it
as best I could,
the beginning we see
Harry when he's abandoned
and he's being rescued
at that moment.
He's actually in the
hands of Dumbledore
after Hagrid has taken
him and rescued him.
He's in the hands of Dumbledore.
But then, at the end, Harry
has experienced so much loss,
but one of the things we learn
through JK Rowling's incredible
story is that it's the power
of love that saves Harry that
you begin to feel will save us,
and so I wanted to have
a glimpse of the love
that Harry had as a
baby from his parents.
So we end with a vision of
him as a baby with his parents
and that cameo of love.
>> And you can see their
cheeks are next to his cheeks.
Actually I can barely
talk about it.
It is so beautiful.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> And also right
underneath, you can see --
I'm looking at it right now.
There's this sort of
-- the train sort of --
>> Yep.
>> Still moving.
And I love that the
Hogwarts Express is actually
on the cover of the last book.
>> Yes.
>> Because it makes
the reader feel
like we can all go to Hogwarts.
>> We can all go to
Hogwarts together.
>> Yeah, the books aren't over.
>> Yeah. And in the coda,
when we move into the future
with the series, and we've
got other children going
to Hogwarts --
>> Yeah.
>> I wanted us to
always be moving forward,
and that's why ultimately
I decided that Harry
and his friends should be
facing into the future.
And so they're facing
into the future,
Hogwarts Express is moving
into the future, because I feel
like the stories leave us
with that kind of hope.
>> And with a --
>> With a forward motion.
>> Propelled forward.
I also -- I'm surprised
to hear you say
that you discovered these books
only two years before you got
the assignment, because there
are so many themes that I feel
like are yours, orphans
and love and loneliness
and finding these -- you must
have felt a real kindred, like,
oh, these are my people.
>> Yes. Most of my stories,
the children are orphans.
>> Yeah.
>> I find that in a
story, having a kid
who doesn't have any parents has
a kind of agency where they have
to go out into the world
and create their own family.
>> Right.
>> So a lot of times I'm
trying to write stories,
that no matter what
you situation is,
we can create our own families.
We can surround ourselves
with people who we love.
And so -- and I knew,
of course --
I mean, I knew a lot about
Harry Potter over the years,
and so I knew that he was an
orphan, and I knew about some
of the general plot points, and
I knew that there were a lot
of themes that overlapped with
things that I cared about.
So I think you're right.
When I finally listened to
the story, and I was able
to really immerse myself in
what JK Rowling had created,
I felt very much like Harry
and Hugo Cabret and so many
of my other characters.
They're all cousins
to each other.
>> Yeah.
>> In some way.
>> Yeah. So before --
I know that we want to
take audience questions,
but I do want to ask, the
final illustrations are so rich
and they have so many details,
Firenze, and the Patronus
and all of these --
what's your favorite?
Is there some tiny Easter egg
that you want to let people --
or do you want everybody
to find their own?
Is there one favorite
moment in this?
>> I mean, it was really fun
going through and making lists
of everything that I
wanted to put in the cover,
so I do actually
have written lists.
>> Oh, I would love
to see that list.
>> Of all of my favorite
moments,
all my favorite characters,
and then trying to figure
out what was going
to fit where was --
like I knew I wanted to draw
Hagrid with the golden egg,
with that egg, the dragon egg,
and I knew I had to get Dobby
in there, since he was
my favorite character.
And then the labyrinth and
the Triwizarding Tournament,
there's a labyrinth
that they have
to go through, it's in right --
>> Oh, right, yes.
>> Over there, yeah.
And so --
>> You stumped me.
>> And then getting to
draw my vision of Hogwarts
as well was really fun, which is
actually based on the train set
at the New York Botanical
Gardens,
their Christmas display.
They have all of the buildings
in New York made out of bark
and twigs and branches
and leaves and acorns,
and so that was one of my
inspirations for Hogwarts.
>> Oh, wow.
>> So trying to get all
of that in was really fun.
>> And it must have been
helpful that you've never had
to consult another vision
of this in your head,
because you hadn't really
-- because we have --
we are bombarded with these
images, be they Disney or --
>> Yeah.
>> Etsy, but wonderfully.
>> I mean all of these different
-- but you never had to --
this arrived fully formed.
>> Yeah.
>> To [inaudible].
>> Even though I hadn't
read the books, of course,
Mary Grandpre's images
are everywhere.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> They're beautiful
and they're iconic.
>> Yeah.
>> So -- and I had seen
some of the movies.
I had seen some parts
of the movies,
and everything is
designed so brilliantly.
>> Yeah.
>> It's all so beautiful, but
ultimately when I had to sit
down to do my version,
it really was --
it wasn't that it was easy
to put all that aside, but --
because I was very aware
of it, and loved all
of it, but it wasn't mine.
>> Right.
>> And what we all have in
common is what JK Rowling wrote.
So the movies come
from the books.
>> Yeah.
>> The parks come
from the books.
Mary Grandpre's images
come from the books.
All the images come
from the books.
So, like, if any of us,
anybody here was asked
to draw their Harry Potter,
we'd all have our own,
so that's what I got to do.
>> That's right.
Well, on that note, let's take
some questions from the audience
and hear about your
own Harry Potters.
Mr. Incredible?
Oh, wait. I'm sorry.
>> We have a microphone.
>> You've got to go
to the microphone.
>> Can you jump over
to the microphone?
>> I work in radio and I
actually skipped the microphone.
Sorry.
>> All right.
>> That's right.
>> So in your making of
the book, box I mean,
how come you didn't decorate
part of it with Death Eaters?
>> With Death Eaters?
Oh, the question is how
come I didn't decorate part
of the box with Death Eaters?
One of the challenges I --
is that I could've decorated
the box with anything,
but one of the things I wanted
to do was try to have Harry
as the focus on the back,
that hidden Voldemort inside,
and then I thought it would
be interesting if each
of the sides could represent
the different houses.
So every choice means
something doesn't get done,
but I thought it
would be interesting
to work on the house crests.
>> Everything's hard.
>> Yeah. You have a
question over here?
Okay, who has the next question?
>> Yeah.
>> I was going to do one more.
On your drawings for the
black and white covers,
I was wondering, you
should've included
like just one Death
Eater on each cover.
>> Oh. Where were you?
Where were you a
couple months ago?
I could've taken that note.
>> Everyone's a critic.
>> But I'm glad that you like
the Death Eaters so much,
because I really did
have fun drawing them,
even though they were so scary.
Yeah?
>> So in terms of Wonderstruck,
do you, like, do all --
because there's like
two stories that are
like interlacing
with each other.
Do you do like all the words
and then all the pictures
or something like that?
>> The question is
about Wonderstruck,
which tells one story
entirely in words
and then a different story
that's 50 years earlier all
in pictures.
And I actually wrote both of
the stories at the same time.
I wrote what I wanted
the picture story to be,
even though I knew it
was going to be pictures,
and then I decided what
pictures would tell that story,
and then wove them
together from there.
So I worked on them
simultaneously.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> What would you do
if a new book came out
and you were asked to --
>> What would I do if a new
Harry Potter book came out
and I was asked to
illustrate the cover?
I think I would have
all the same feelings.
I would get really
nervous again,
and then I'd feel really honored
again, and then I would sit down
and figure out what would be
the best way to tell this story.
But having told the entire
series, of the seven series,
I feel pretty pleased
with what I have there.
Can we get another question?
Yeah.
>> What is your favorite
Harry Potter book?
>> What is my favorite
>> Good question.
>> That's a really
good question.
I really do look at all
of them as a single story,
because when I'm asked
what was my favorite moment
or what was my favorite
part, I don't remember
which book it happened in.
I remember that it happened in
the lifetime of Harry Potter,
but I do remember the
Triwizarding event was
particularly exciting.
The battle itself became
one of my favorites,
and sort of the story
art with what happened
with Dobby was one
of my favorites.
>> Yeah.
>> I think we can get in
maybe one more question.
>> Hi, yeah, so early on
in your talk you mentioned
that you decided very early
on that the covers would be
in black and white, and I was
hoping you could elaborate a
little more on that
and which parts
of the Harry Potter story
made you, led you to believe
that black and white
was the right choice.
>> Yeah, no, I love drawing
in black and white and I think
that black and white is a very
mysterious way to make an image,
because it asks you to
use your imagination,
because the world actually
isn't in black and white.
So when we see something
in black and white,
it might remind us of an old
movie or an old photograph,
and then we, in our minds, fill
in what else might be there.
So we might see a black and
white drawing of a landscape,
and in our minds we might be
aware that the sky is blue
and the grass is green,
even though that's not
actually what we're seeing.
So there's something
else happening
in our mind that's adding to
what's there, and that process
where the viewer has
to bring something else
to the image is exciting to me.
And I thought because there's
so much happening in these books
and they're so mysterious,
that it might be nice to do it
in black and white so that
the reader can add parts
of their own imagination
to finish the images.
So that's why I wanted to
do it in black and white.
>> I think that's where
we have to leave it.
But thank you so much, Brian,
and could we have
a great big hand --
round of applause for him.
>> Thank you.
>> Yea. And look very
carefully at this.
It's so wonderful.
Thank you.